is this house governor and five of us
these odds are terrible we need new odds
what a fit when we get one chance to
save the galaxy twice here you stand
here a garden of the galaxy guardians of
the galaxy why would we be the guardians
of the galaxy
hey youtubers its charlie brand new
guardians footage let's break it down we
also got confirmed Guardians three and
I'm gonna do my top stories for what I
think that should be including one
really big spider-man story if you're
new to the channel I do comic book
videos every week be sure to subscribe
to get everything and leave all your
requests in the comments below and even
though this clip is just meant to be a
funny week at the odds that they face
the sovereign is like the big villain of
the movie this big race of genetically
perfect people the twist I think in them
surviving these odds like Drax says we
need to get new odds is in the idea of
family because you're talking about
Peter Quill's family ego the Living
Planet people that you would normally
think are villains in this monster at
the beginning of the movie that the
sovereign hire them to get rid of so if
you remember that funny twist from Thor
the dark world with the beast from Yount
I'm basically like the giant dog monster
like this huge house sized monster that
was sort of skipping through the end of
the movie
I'm wondering if they're gonna do the
same thing in the Guardians movie with
his giant tentacle monster because James
Gunn said that it's called the Apple s
he said that it's an interdimensional
creature that doesn't necessarily think
of itself as bad but you see them
fighting it in all the trailers so you
just kind of assume that it's one of the
antagonists like oh it's a big monster
for them to defeat but the whole idea is
the ego the Living Planet looks like
this giant monster but he's really Peter
Quill's father
so whatever ends up happening with this
big encounter that they're hyping up it
just feels like it's going to come back
and really funny wait because the
sovereign are the true villains of the
film so they're the ones to take down
not the Apple esque the tentacle monster
but you guys may have heard that James
Gunn confirmed that there's gonna be a
third guardians film I really love the
cosmic side of the Universe I really I
love Marvel superheroes but i-i've made
guardians if you consider guardians a
superhero film I've now made four
superhero films The Specials super
Gardens the galaxy vol 1 guardians of
galaxy vol 2 but what interests me more
about guardians of galaxy isn't that the
superhero aspect what interests me is
the space opera aspect it's more of a
science fiction space opera film to me
and so that's what that's what is really
interesting to me right now and that's
the kind of movie I want to make more so
than a superhero movie so
so are there superheroes I love yes I've
talked about those superheroes I've
loved I love Moon Knight I love the
Thunderbolts
I love hit monkey not exactly a
superhero so there's a lot of Marvel I
love Squirrel Girl
there's a lot of superheroes I really
love I love Shazam I love Batman I mean
these are these are all characters that
are great but but I'm not sure you know
what I want to do right now I love
making space operas more than that
though I've committed the past three
years of my life to making guardians of
the galaxy vol 2 as special and is
beautiful and is wonderful and it's
truthful as I possibly can and it's it's
at the end of a marathon for me where
we're dealing with you know
20800 visual effect shots in the movie I
have to go over hundreds every day
finish them make them as perfect as I
possibly can we have some of the biggest
visual effects shots in fact I'll say
the biggest visual effects shots in any
movie ever in terms of the actual amount
of data within those shots as well as
the length of some of those shots so
dealing with that stuff is taking up a
lot of time and I'm gonna need a break
after this I really I just need a break
I need to relax for two seconds but I'm
also excited about writing again so who
knows so I'm gonna explain my top five
stories now James Gunn didn't confirm
that he was going to direct Guardians 3
a lot of people are pointing to that
they're like well his language was kind
of iffy he said that they're working on
a story for Guardians 3 but he didn't
really say what his involvement is and
in the past he's been kind of iffy about
whether or not he will do another one
he's like I don't you know I don't know
I have all the money in the world
he really likes making small indie
movies so I will say right off the bat I
totally think that he will be fully
involved with guardians 3 I think he
just needs a break because it's been
such a marathon finishing this film so
don't worry about that it's not like
James Gunn is gonna leave the franchise
Joss Whedon style but he loves these
characters so much he's invested so much
time in them that there are actually a
couple really solid picks that he's
clued us in on in the past about what
the story is going to revolve around in
that next film so number 5 rocket and
Groot spin-off film technically not a
spin-off film because it would have the
other guardians in it but it would be
more focused on their characters so
there's no specific storyline like war
of kings or something like that just
pulling from the very first rocket
racoon solo title he basically had like
a 5 issue run that started in 1985 Mike
Mignola from Hellboy Fame actually did
the cover for this so it basically tells
his origin story he's a creature from
half world where they're these people
the genetically engineer animals like
rocket is genetically engineered to be
loonies for their amusement so it's a
story about him trying to say to the
person he loves and try to fight against
the people that are doing this to them
there's this really weird story about
how half world exists in a part of the
galaxy that sort of walled off from
everything else so wherever they pull
from in the comics for the next story
most of it will revolve around rocket
and Groot but number four pick Angela
everybody's
when we're gonna see Angela in the
universe but hella over in thor ragnarok
kind of feels like a Helicarrier so it's
not like they're gonna double up but I
feel like they could bring in a new
character to the Marvel Universe even if
it's not Angela through that storyline
because Angela is from heaven the tenth
realm which is something that flows out
of the Thor comics but what happens in
her storyline is that there's this rift
in space-time that allows her to escape
into the normal galaxy she finds herself
there and ends up teaming up with the
guardians so you learn a lot about her
character against the backdrop of the
original sin storyline which is a very
watcher heavy story I don't know if
they'll ever get to original sin because
that's something you do really at the
end of a big story
so the ramping up for Infinity Ward the
heroes will be eventually successful
after Thanos hands than their asses with
the Infinity Gauntlet usually original
sin would be a story that you do after
that because sometimes in the pursuit of
defeating the villain like Thanos you
have to do really bad things original
sin was a storyline that was meant to
let all those skeletons out of all those
characters closets so it's like you did
something bad a long time ago that
nobody else knows about well they're
gonna find out about it so I'll say
number three in original sin Thanos
Bay's story they did that in the comics
it basically covered this missing time
period where Peter quill was trying to
defeat Thanos and get the Cosmic Cube
away from him they were stuck in the
cancerverse it was getting ready to
explode around them but when our
characters die in the cancerverse they
immediately come back so it's almost
like this never-ending cycle of death
and rebirth that sounds like dormammu's
dark dimensions so I feel like they'll
try to use that in interesting ways
during phase four maybe not again in
phase 3 because Thanos is going to be
mostly focused with destroying half of
all life in our universe
Dormammu I've come to bargain they're
just so much stuff happening during
infinity war you don't want to
overcomplicate it by dealing with a
thousand different universes but you do
want to remind people that it's out
there but because that next Guardians
film might not come till phase four is
still totally valid
so cancerverse Dark Dimension right or
Die number two Guardians disassembled so
that was actually a more recent
storyline a lot of people didn't really
like the more recent Guardians story
where Peter quill was head of the sparta
empire there have been a whole lot of
changes to his backstory from the comics
his father isn't JSON of spartax it's
actually ego the Living Planet in the
movies but the whole idea is that Peter
quill takes his father's place as leader
of the Empire
so imagine Peter quill becoming the
leader of one of the empires in space
there's no way you can make that stick
but all the guardians are separated as
the title guardians disassembled implies
they have to bring the team back
together against the backdrop of this
fight against the Horde of the Badoon
the Badoon are kind of like space Nazis
in the Marvel Universe they're really
bad they seem like the scrolls but
they're not quite the same thing but my
number one pick I want them to do this
so bad and I don't think that they'll
ever get to it but it would be so
awesome is the planet of the symbiote
storyline in a more recent benda
storyline when venom was traveling with
them venom space night they get attacked
by other symbiotes from their home
planet the Clint are and it's sort of an
origin story of the Venom symbiote so
they could make it a spider-man
crossover but I feel like there's no way
that they're gonna put spider-man with
the Guardians so it's very unlikely that
they would do that but I feel like
because spider-man is so tied up with
the MCU now it would just make sense if
Sony is hurting for money so this gets
into more financial stuff but Sony's box
office has been terrible the last couple
of years the studio's losing money so
it's trying to do everything it can to
get people to come see its movies and
that means a whole lot of spider-man
they're doing an animated spider-man
with Miles Morales they're doing the
live-action films with Tom Holland
they're doing all the crossovers with
the MCU why not take advantage of other
spider-man characters and do a symbiote
storyline so you don't have to make it
the main focus of the
like I said most of the third film will
focus on rocket and Groot scare achter
their origin story but let me know in
the comments what do you want them to do
for the third guardians film and how
long do you think it's gonna take them
to get to symbiote in the MCU
I feel like phase four is a pretty good
target for that because they'll have at
least two spider-man solo films under
their belt and they'll have a plan if
they haven't already made a sinister six
movie or a Bennet movie those were all
projects that were being planned before
Sony made the deal with Marvel so they
got put on the Shelf they're like okay
we're gonna handle Tom Holland for now
we'll visit this stuff later so base 4
is that later so we'll say
congratulations to the latest Marvel
giveaway winner RBR HD you win those
spider-man Hasbro action figures please
private message me on the back end of my
channel so I can get your contact
details there was a new round that
started in this video I'll remind
everyone when I post new Avengers
Infinity Ward NYX so I'll be talking
about Infinity Gauntlet stuff tonight
and don't forget iron fist drops at
midnight Pacific Standard Time while you
wait for that click here for my
non-spoilery iron fist review and click
here to learn all about the Black Order
in infinity war thank you so much for
watching let's high-five I'll see you in
the next video
you